we're having a meeting tomorrow those
are getting really stale if you ask me
happy Wednesday everybody so let's talk
fashion
yeah everyone was ragging on Senator
Kirsten Cinema for that bright yellow
dress last night I thought it looked
great once she peeled off the sticker
that said Chiquita
but I love I love that banana look
that's how you put the ass in potassium
and you can't falter for wearing
shoulder pads during Super Bowl week
by the way I own that same dress and she
totally wore it better
I look like a fire hydrant I had to stop
wearing it after two dogs peed on me in
Central Park
I didn't mind
so I guess we should do the State of the
Union I know it's news but it's not news
to me or to you really maybe you use
those 72 minutes while Biden was
speaking to do something better with
your time like rubbing your
grandfather's bunion or retrieving that
dead mouse from behind your fridge
I taught my dog Gus how to poop on
command when he hears the word Pelosi
because one good turd deserves another
now if I can get him to stop humping
legs when he hears the word Cuomo
but if you didn't see the speech here's
a summary of what you missed
[Music]
actually that guy moved faster Biden
said a bunch of stuff that wasn't true
when Republicans called him out for
being more full of crap than Joy Behar
after a night is scotch and Taco Bell
that's a bad mix Roland Ramon
some Republicans want Medicare and
Social Security Sunset I'm not saying
it's a majority
that means Congress doesn't vote
well I'm glad fentanyl is killing more
than 70 000 Americans a year
[Applause]
you got it
[Laughter]
for some reason a Doctor Jill gave
kamala's husband mouth to mouth
and he wasn't even unconscious
makes you wonder about the state of
their Union
we'll be right back
as for the whole Affair what was once a
unifying exercise is now just a batting
cage for political campaign rhetoric and
it's done in a way that's less real than
Madonna's face
just listen
would we stand for the most basic of
principles
where we stand for sovereignty we stand
for the right of people to live free of
tyranny
will we stand for the defense of
democracy
yeah whatever but uh
what's the problem here I mean it's so
obvious but no one ever says it no one
talks like this anymore our so-called
leaders still sound like they're emoting
to Their audience like they're at a
train stop in 1860. the words are like
Joe himself they're Dusty musty and when
sniffing the head of a child Lusty
it's always weird because Joe's yelling
never ever matches the content itself
it's as if the Hall of Presidents at
Disney suddenly started faking orgasms
but I'm starting to think that no one
ever talked like this ever and even when
he wasn't faking sincerity Joe was a
mess but make no mistake if we try to
raise the cost of reasons
he will veto it
make no mistake
if you try anything to raise the cost of
Brazilian jobs I will veto it
[Applause]
I'm glad we cleared that up
those those Vision joggers are they're
getting really expensive I I can't I
can't afford my physical campaign
but political speech is weird where it's
granted immunity from the demands of
Truth and it's especially noticeable
when the speaker claims to be for Unity
as he lies about the other side's intent
and if you dare question that then
you're being uncivil but there's less
truth in last night's speech than in a
brochure for penile enlargement ew
what a rip-off that was
and it's why all that jeering from
Republicans were a sign of progress It's
2023 smothering 1853 with a my pillow
because we should no longer respect the
artifice of this manufactured oratory
especially when all it does is
regurgitate platitudes hell imagine if
someone talked like that in everyday
life
foreign
I know speed dating isn't easy but how
about you guys tell me about yourselves
well Brenda thank you so much for that
great question
I think my record speaks for itself I'm
all about Solutions unlike my opponent
here voters agree my charm is undeniable
I also support the troops thank you so
much for your time God Bless America
[Music]
okay and how about you
yeah you know I'm uh taking things slow
just trying to find the right woman for
me and uh we'll see where things go
really
okay I've made my decision guy number
one what are you kidding me this guy's
so fake did you not see that well you're
not wearing any pants
they said bottomless brunch
bottomless
[Music]
all right
I didn't see that coming I didn't see
that coming okay so the heckling last
night may just be a Natural Evolution
humans moving away from non-human
behavior and moving towards something
real it's why Trump worked the stories
about water pressure and Rosie O'Donnell
tell me this wasn't relatable thanks
toilets and showers
you don't get any water how about the
shower you go into a shower and I have
this beautiful head of hair I need a lot
of water and you go into the shower
right
you turn on the water drip
drip
drip yeah he could rattle off a lie or
two but they were his
because he wasn't a politician armed
with political speech and political
speech is not designed to share
information it's designed to hide the
truth and confuse issues to make you
wonder what the meaning of the word is
is but when you speak like a human other
humans can understand you so while a lot
of people are criticizing the
Republicans for heckling at least that
is easily understood you lie about me
I'm going to call you out on it whether
you're the president or a Mindless old
fart or both
what else welcome tonight's guess her
name sounds like three characters from
Game of Thrones Deputy opinion editor at
newswrite
he looks like the gym teacher who smokes
cigarettes while making you run the mile
comedian Joe DeRosa
she's so thin you can use her as a dryer
filter Fox News contributor cats him
[Applause]
and finally he mends his socks with a
space needle my massive sidekick in the
NWA World Heavyweight Champion Tyrus
Joe uh I'm going to assume that you did
not watch this I didn't no you have no
idea what went on last night no I have
full ideas okay okay tell me what you
think whether they're accurate or not I
don't know yes but they are my own
that's good uh no I I watch clips and I
read up on it and everything and look I
think some of what you said has validity
uh or worth I think it's a good idea I
think you've got the entirely wrong
mouthpieces going for Marjorie Taylor
yeah Miss green yeah is a horror show uh
whether you hate Biden or not I don't
care she's a horror show she's she's the
worst mouthpiece for what you want she's
she's your drunk wife at dinner with
your boss going he deserves a break
he works hard for this company
and you're going honey
[Laughter]
and that's the problem I I I I agree
that that uh the elder abuse of
Wheeling this man helps to speak
we wouldn't even let my grandfather give
a wedding toast
I get it I know we're not in great shape
but can we not have somebody collected
with with decorum to to combat this well
you're coming also I mean you're a
comedian so you don't like heckling I
hate heckling yeah yeah I think uh you
know but also be a good Heckler yeah
that's true that's true be a good
Heckler yeah that's all yeah so when
you're at one of Joe's uh uh uh comedy
shows
you had to think of what word to use yes
I was trying to think what do we call
those things
Open Mic nights at the Y
gotcha I love saying your name what was
the uh what was your take on last night
um I have to say I loved it
um I love that the second gentleman and
the first lady got some action yes
starting with that I loved Kirsten
Cinema's dress I love the heckling and I
loved the speech I thought the speech
was very trumpy I mean he spent a lot of
time focused on bringing manufacturing
back to the United States why shouldn't
the U.S be number one in manufacturing
he spent a lot of time on fentanyl he
spent a lot of time talking about issues
that were important president Trump
Social Security and when he veered off
track there was a lovely Greek chorus
booing him and yelling China border you
know to get him back on track I thought
it was great and it weird to use yeah
we're going to edit all that out
it's kind of interesting in this analogy
of the husband and wife thing and it is
true I think of when Democrats and
Republicans work well they're like a
married couple somebody says something
stupid the other one says knock it off
right and it's like and I think that's
how I think the problem with the with
the way the country has been running is
that it's just one party and especially
in cities there's no husband anymore
it's just the crazy liberal wife
cat uh I wanted to ask did you you
didn't watch it did you I watched I read
it yes and then I like I watched some of
it what were your thoughts
I'm just upset he doesn't seem to watch
the show because he did the thing again
that drives me nuts what when he talks
about our soul as a nation yes it is I
know he thinks it's sweet but it's so
collectivist and creepy and weird to me
there's no soul there's the nation
doesn't have a soul I don't care if you
talk about it in the religious sense or
the secular sense the soul is an
individual thing right and I know they
already you know he says he's also a
capitalist before he lists off all the
ways that you know he can spend my money
better than I can which that's not what
that means but you also want to extend
your power to my actual Soul like I
believe in a separation of state and
soul yes exactly
but the soul of an of uh you're at the
Super Bowl and you you go the soul of
the of the of the fans it doesn't make
any sense it's impossible the value of
an individual and to be who you are as
an individual there's it's collectivist
and creepy and weird and it makes my
skin crawl whenever he says it your skin
is crawling right before me oh my God yo
um I want to play this my favorite tape
from last night uh uh Tyrus uh do we
have the tape where Joe points out
probably one of the biggest problems
that we're facing as a country
we're going to ban surprise Resort fees
that hotels charge on your bill those
fees can cost up to 90 a night in hotels
that aren't even resorts
they Pirates they aren't even Resorts
well as many as you had to pay for a
hunter I get it
you know I'm not even sure he meant Soul
yeah he might have been trying to say
roll the role of the country we we just
don't know yeah you know uh I sat
through the 72 minutes of that it was
either that or listen to her talk about
her day so I went with
uh and both were about the same here's
the thing
um
I missed the good old comedies like
Blazing Saddles and there was one
character that I thought no one else
could do he was on the roof and he threw
a problem and it was old western
Shooters Harvest well yeah and Biden
brought it back so that to me was nice
but on the serious side he had a
solution for
Hotel fees but his answer for the
fentanyl poisoning in this country was
more drug monitoring machines at points
of Entry where they're not going yeah so
if you could please do Fizz and fathom
when you talk about other the solution
for the fentanyl poisoning is
I could at least go I don't know what he
said but I hope he's going to do it but
the star of the show was George Santos
yes he was sitting there going isn't
this great yeah
I'm home yeah yeah he made he's like my
lies nothing this is crazy yes if you
look at him he was laughing and smiling
all the time that's how you get off the
hook you lie a bunch of bunches and then
you go to a place where they lie all
night and suddenly you're he's right at
home he's where he needs to be by the
way the the the behavior the energy in
this room of we're of seeing this sort
of what some would say is an unhinged
you know energy yeah that we haven't
really seen before I I'm dead serious
I've been saying since the fentanyl
thing happened when you start to take
recreational drugs out of the picture
for people
people start to get a little on edge you
know what I mean they can't just go out
and have a good time on the weekend
without worrying I might drop dead in
the bathroom right there is no industry
outside of the music industry more
dependent on cocaine than politics
[Laughter]
been removed from their lives
look at how on
how long
about all think about Wall Street all
those guys right every weekend they're
going this could be it
switch to smelling salts
those are the true victims cokeheads I'm
gonna do a special on Fox Nation hosted
by the entire Baldwin family
[Applause]
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else